- I have Justin Timberlake
and Anna Kendrick
with me on Zoom.
My first Zoom interview.
And anyway, the cool thing
about talking remotely
is we get to see people's homes,
and we get to kind of peer
into their quarantine lives.
So I know a lot of
people are playing games
or doing puzzles and all those things.
So I thought that we
would do a game as well.
And I know how much celebrities
just love doing games
on shows, so I thought you would, too.
So (laughs), we're gonna do a game called
Zoom around the Room.
(game show music)
Here's how it goes.
We'll be given, by my producer
we'll be given a word or a
phrase, and we will each run
to find the object that matches that word.
First person, I see, okay I
thought Justin was stretching.
I thought, man, he's
really getting into this
but he's (laughs)
- No, I'm looking.
I'm like, whoa, okay,
okay, taking inventory.
- You look like, you're like
in a padded, white room,
so good luck finding stuff. (laughs)
The first person back to the camera
with the item gets the point, okay?
So they're gonna type in something.
I'm gonna read it off.
I don't know either, so
we're just gonna grab stuff.
And then whoever's back gets a point.
And then you need to explain
why you pulled that thing.
Are you ready?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Zoom around the room.
Okay, so Alex, why don't
you give us the first clue?
Okay, so go find something red!
- Okay.
- [Kelly] Something red!
(timer ticking)
Oh my god! Oh wait! (laughs)
I killed y'all.
- I'm not gonna be fast, guys.
I'm not gonna be fast.
- I killed y'all!
Okay, I'm gonna try to
walk slower for you.
I'm in a small cabin, y'all.
There's not many places to hide stuff.
- I don't like the color red that much.
And I don't have much red.
- What?! Who doesn't like the color red?!
We're gonna have to talk about that later.
- Okay.
- I definitely had this urge to be like
(laughter)
- Look what's funny, this is mine!
We're so in Montana.
(laughter)
Okay, go ahead, Anna, and explain yours.
What is that?
- This is a can of wine.
(laughter)
Hi.
- Next time, I'm quarentining
with you. (laughs)
- Yeah, I mean, the sun is
out, so what are we doing?
- Did you say a can of wine?
Very fancy, and maybe a nice...
- It's a all-day, right?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- And it's red, so I'm good.
- Okay, so what is yours,
Justin, other than your shirt?
- This is a mixing bowl from this morning.
I was talking about those
banana chocolate chip muffins.
- Okay, I'm actually in the room
where I happen to quilt and do crafts.
So, I'm a quilter.
So this is um...
I know, it's like, once
you have kids it's like,
I'm gonna do these motherly things.
And then, whatever, I don't
know, you become weird.
But anyway, so I have that.
That's, like, one of the pieces I use.
Okay, next clue!
Kelly gets first point.
Yes!
Find something from your childhood?!
What?
- Find something from your childhood?
- Find something from your childhood!
- Oh, gosh.
- Whoo!
I got something.
Oh my god, did I win again?!
- [Justin] I don't have anything.
Something from my childhood?
- Fun fact, I wore that veil as a shaw
to the Tony Awards when
I was 12-years-old.
- (gasps) When you were how old?
- 12-years-old.
- Wait, what?
Wait, I missed something.
You went to the Tony
Awards at 12-years-old?
- I was nominated!
Did you not know? (laughs)
- At 12-years-old?!
- Yeah.
- [Justin] What did I miss?
- [Kelly] Holy Crap!
- Yeah, like what?
- Nobody told me that.
I did not know that, Anna!
- It's weird. (laughs)
- That's incredible!
- I know, it's weird.
- What were you in?
What did you do?
- I was in the musical "High Society,"
which is based on the,
like, Grace Kelly movie.
Which is based on the musical.
- I knew "High Society!"
I didn't know that.
That is so cool.
- It's so wild.
Like, sometimes I'm like, what?
- Learning something new on Zoom, okay.
Okay, what did you find
from your childhood?
(laughs) What is that?
- There was just some old,
there was just some old,
you know the old, just letters
where you're teaching your kids to spell.
This is one that I had
that we brought up here.
I picked a K, just for
"Kelly" and "Kendrick."
- Good job!
Totally for bookpile, right?
- This is one
that's been passed on to my little guy.
It's the K in "Timberlake."
- You are so full of crap right now,
but I'm okay with it.
- No, no, no!
This is true, this is true, this is--
- That is?!
I thought you just grabbed
a toy from your kid
and were like, "Yeah, this was passed down
from my great grandmother."
- No, no, no.
This shows you I'm not
willing to spend money
on new toys for my children.
I just passed down.
- That's adorable!
It's passed down that much,
like, really cool! (laughs)
- Yeah, there are all these,
just to, you know, spelling.
Here's your letters.
- Okay, this is,
I made sure to bring this with me
because I love NES.
- Oh, wow!
- Yes, and I'm just
gonna be honest with you.
They have the new one, where it came out,
and you got all the
games from your childhood
like, on this, because we're
all around the same age.
Anyway, I'm not gonna lie.
If you played me at Mario-anything,
I would make you feel
so bad about yourself
'cause I'm so talented at it.
I'm so good.
I'm just saying.
Did you play Mario Brothers?
I will crush anyone I'm playing.
My husband, it's sad.
He just drinks.
- Does that Nintendo come with Excitebike?
- Yes!
- It does?
- Oh my gosh, with the hill, yes!
- That was, damn.
I remember when you
bought the first Nintendo,
it would come with, like, Mario Brothers
and then--
- Duck Hunt.
- Yeah, Duck Hunt, and
then, I think, Excitebike.
Or, maybe (audio cuts out).
I don't know.
- No, that was awesome.
Yeah, anyway, I love playing this
while inebriated, just gonna
say inebriated, yeah. (laughs)
- No this, you know,
drinking, let's all be real.
It's happening.
- It's happening right now. (laughs)
- Yeah.
Anyway, okay, so, this is the last one
because I'm long-winded,
and you're welcome, team.
Anyway, we have to find
something related to you.
Okay, find related--
- What does that mean?
What does that mean?
- [Kelly] Metaphorically or physical.
(timer ticking)
- Wait, wait, wait.
Does this count as related to me?
- Boom.
- Oh, look at what we just did! (laughs)
I stole my kid's toy.
- I got one better than that.
I stole my kid. (laughs)
- Awwwww!
- This is River.
- Aw, Kelly wins again.
Hi!
- Oh, hey, come here!
They were about to head
out with our niece.
So come here!
This is Remi.
We were just watching Trolls.
So this is Branch, and this is Poppy.
- Hi.
- Hi!
- Can you say hi?
- Hi.
- You did your hair, man?
Okay.
Somebody thought they
were gonna be on camera.
Hey, can you say bye to them?
- Byyyeee!
- Do you like Trolls?
- Bye!
- You love Trolls.
- And I loved your acting.
I love Poppy and Bridgette.
- (laughs) And Branch.
- (audio cuts out)
- Oh my god.
- Aright, were you kind of worried
that mommy was gonna be a mean troll?
Yeah?
- [River] No.
Look at her face!
Alright, so, sorry,
something related to you.
What did you get, Anna?
- I got Poppy.
- Oh my god, you both! (laughs)
- Well I was, it was related to me!
Nobody's in the house.
- That's awesome.
That's related to you.
There you go.
This was perfect.
That's amazing.
Okay, cool.
Alright, well the winner
is, was there a doubt?
It's me, yep.
Anna, you came in second.
But, you know, if you're
not first, you're last.
Thank y'all for doing this.
It's entertaining to
people that are at home
and don't have anything, you know, to do.
And they're bored, and
so, thank you so much
for just taking the time, 'cause I know
that all of us are going
through it as well,
so sometimes, it sucks, you have to smile
and be like, "It's gonna be great!"
Even though in your head,
you're like, "It might not be."
- I'm just gonna have a little cry
and then go back to saying that
everything's gonna be great.
- Yeah (laughs).
Anyway--
- It's gonna be okay!
- I am glad that you're safe in Montana
and staying healthy.
Justin, say hi to your family for us.
Glad you just had a birthday
party with your kiddos, Alex.
And Anna, thank you so much for coming on
and looking, just, fabulous,
and if I'm in quarantine,
next time, I want you to be with me.
So that you can do my
hair and makeup. (laughs)
All right, well, I love you guys,
and I'll just see y'all next time
maybe in person, how about that?
- (laughs) Yes.
- [Justin] Yeah, I would
love that, I would love that.